[Music]
in music genetics news submitted by
Google Maps oh all right okay they got a
brain they do they're smart Spotify has
partnered with ancestry to use your DNA
to curate playlists no racist Tiffany
all salsa music seems you have African
genetics is this how it felt wouldn't
move like a bunch of us horse owners saw
the first like car like the Model T and
we're all like no this is the
progression of Technology we're all like
very like not really a progression of
technology they're basically
stereotyping based on your ancestry to
what music you would like yeah well you
know what it's not a progression no it
is no freedom of music choices of
progression no would it be thirds I go
for it ditching okay I will defend it
are you ready for this I'm really Rob
was wrong I take about eight years ago I
was really pissed because Google did
this thing were you used to be able to
type in whatever you wanted and then
Google would listen to you but then
you're just typing a letter and then
Google says like you probably look at
this already narrow everything I was
like [ __ ] this [ __ ] I'm looking for and
now if I have to type more than three
keys on my are so many [ __ ] key and
so now what if I only have to type in
any wait wait but this time it's gonna
be like oh you're white you probably are
looking up insurance yeah or you're
white you probably love Garth Brooks and
you know what he's right I do know I
didn't know that about you
damn right I do just like street cred
terrible music I want to try it cuz a
lot of people are like I think we're
good on giving our DNA to all these
babies that's what I don't want the
Illuminati owns the music industry why
they want your DNA 60 minutes yeah I
don't mind being cloned and then plus I
mean if you're really thinking that it's
like well they could get my DNA from
anywhere honestly if they really wanted
exactly thank you Tim I'd wait in my
freaking with yourself I'm not talking
about anyway yeah so Spotify is now
working with ancestry DNA which is the
ancestry.com DNA portion of that and
they are saying that they are curating
these playlists based on your top I
think it's five top five genetic makeup
or whatever you are so like for example
are some people have already done it and
they have like like African or like from
the UK and like they're creating these
playlists like of songs that they might
be speaking to their soul it sounds bad
that's all [ __ ] up I can picture like
mine was like 90% Chinese no I think
[Laughter]
didn't Cisco wasn't he's like did he
have like some sort of asian fetish
thing going on with this whole persona I
remember that we should do hip hop we
should do hip hop ancient aliens because
that's what the origins is from the Ming
Dynasty that's where the thong song is
gonna be a lot better like they know
your DNA and not by like ethnic type
it's more like oh it's actually in your
DNA that you would prefer
oh that would be sick or like hype music
or whatever that would know what you say
no they're doing it or doing it by oh
that's right culturally your peoples
listen to hip-hop that's stupid
because like they can kind of determine
other things about you like if you like
spicy foods right like your earwax and
[ __ ] 23 mean yeah I guess ancestry.com
is different because that one's about
like your your ethnic group and whatever
sure but yeah like yeah I was thinking
the other one they're like oh you're
white you probably shop at j.crew yeah I
like it when um like people try their
best to not be their stereotype but deep
down inside they absolutely love it yeah
it's like don't even hide it man
fighting it yeah don't fight it like
don't be some Asian kids at school that
they'll be like oh no like I'm a
different kind of Asian cuz like cuz I
suck at math man it's like but then like
deep down inside like they actually like
math like is that hey what you working
on he's like nothing no tree cheering
yeah I've drawn tits got a big tits it's
like well look like the number a psych
no look there's nipples see I just dot
all the number eight no
yeah just a lot of people are like I
don't like this they want our DNA too
badly now yeah they're gonna get it
though they have our fingers yeah but I
don't make it easy for them they don't
have yours now I'll put it an apple hey
good for you then we will give them our
fingerprint we will fully put listening
devices in our homes
facial recognition things yeah the CIA
when they saw when they saw that we were
doing facial recognition yet next they
were like like they couldn't believe how
lucky they no I think Facebook has it so
it's optional like the facial
recognition thing wait there's a phone
where wasn't option yeah no they would
automatically tag you in it be like oh
[ __ ] you're at this person's photo no
just cuz they're not tagging you doesn't
mean they're not like mapping all of it
they secretly map in my face stop having
my face if people wanted your DNA or
whatever all they have to do is go to
the [ __ ] sewer and collect all the
Dookie and they got a cesspool of that
[ __ ] but they wouldn't know what these
whoo yeah but that's a lot of DNA so
it's just an orgy of DNA some of the
funniest stories I've ever read is the
CIA trying to collect Fidel Castro's
[ __ ] during the Cold War yeah yeah yeah
that's some crazy [ __ ] dude it's all
funny yeah they were trying to get his
poop cuz they wanted to like test him
and see like what his weaknesses were
diseases or whatever the [ __ ] we really
wanted to kill him real bad well we
couldn't get told you hear about the
poison cigar that they try to you know
what's that one know that well they just
try to sneak in a poisons because they
knew these smoke loss cigars and so they
tried to sneak it up poison cigars that
he would hopefully smoke and die well I
gave to a son to smoke first
those guys are badasses do they didn't
[ __ ] around he survived like multiple
attempts of assassination from the US
yeah
imagine being that person Yeah right yes
it's like your Fidel's food tester maybe
just took your first day at work first
and last yeah right and it's like yeah I
just got the job like the last guy
didn't work out it's like ya didn't
how old was he he was gonna long to
collect like severance pay or whatever
like no no I don't know I feel like this
I mean I kind of with you job like well
I've already given my DNA to 23 me and I
think I can't remember but I think I did
do ancestry DNA also how badly did you
want to know you're from Mexico no
because it gave me a free one so I was
like okay fine might as well I don't
remember seeing the results or not
remember logging in oh really cuz you're
whiter than you wanted to admit from
span at Spain yeah like that like Europe
and here in North America
mmm but every Mexican has the same dude
yeah like we're all mutts I bet you the
same with Philippines yeah if you if you
get the DNA of like the Mexican that
looked really indigenous they'll be
different
oh for sure yeah yeah the ones that were
like we never [ __ ] the Spaniard appear
as tech over here cuz mine was like I
was like hoping that I had a mix of
Asian but it was basically 99% Japanese
say same you did it - yeah say I got
like 99% Japanese in like 1% Korean and
then like a fraction or a percent like
other you're both created yeah the
Filipinos that like most Filipinos are
look look kind of like brownish Asian
yeah but like the Filipinos that are
like really pure filled you know they
look super Asian like they're yeah they
look almost like Chinese or like yeah
that is true so genetically you guys
should both love kpop 1% of us I will
say give us like algae popping in like
one here in song about this I wish they
would be more specific is all karaoke
jams what's the difference what's the
difference between kpop and j-pop firing
taking away yeah I don't think Brian's
getting this video I want to know
[Music]
a genuine what is curried what is jammin
iam pop and Japan pop but is there like
a all difference like can you know like
I think musically there's a difference
in structure I mean they're both pop
music but I think Korean pop it has a
lot more Western influence definitely
like they they hire a lot of producers
from from Hollywood that that are like
top producers for celebrities out here
and then they hire them to go back and
train their artists and and and in music
and all kinds of the sound of it is not
different is that a little boy it is to
the untrained ear know maybe dun dun da
da dun da dun dun dun dun da da da da
it's not like that at all Tiffany I
don't think it's like oh it's not like
that at all that doesn't make any sense
everyone's seen male j-pop the only seen
female of kpop there's no Jews they're
out there cuz all I see is male Korean
pop but there's this female Korean pop
to you like one girl bang I mean
it'sit's pop news the groups of them
regardless where they would like the
cute little outfits
he doesn't know something and then he's
like what
there's I know one right you just got
pantsed hard to it and then he's like
well maybe yeah there's like just gotta
[ __ ] love sure like cuz when we were
in Japan and we were because I remember
we went to a bar one time and they were
playing a whole bunch of music videos
and it was like j-pop and the girl bands
there were like 30 thousand of them in
one group it was just like an insane
amount of people and I think they're
called idol groups or something like
that but then it's like a whole crew of
girls just like flash mob it's like a
Bollywood movie but it's ya ya know
they're all wearing like the same outfit
and you're a part of one group that's
kind of dough that's a really cool idea
Julie I really like that and it's it's
like imagine if like you know how there
you have those 30 group dance crew yeah
so imagine it's like they dance but they
also sing I want it yeah I want it they
have like personalities too so like they
have one for every type of guy or girl
that would like that's so cool like
overall but yeah it'll be like a nerd
the hot one they're like rather like her
like right hand put everybody it's like
the deaf guy everybody it's like the
driver honestly a particularly Jeff the
girl with the eye patch everybody
covered like those Nintendo Me's yeah
exactly
plus size and you have the super skinny
and you have the everywhere in between
that's cool lover
[Music]